- Let's wrap up with
one last awesome story.
This is what I'm liking.
So Willie Nelson is surprising
kids in children's hospitals
around Akron, Ohio, but no,
I do not mean that Willie Nelson.
Though I know he's all
about doing kind acts
for the world as well.
This Willie Nelson is an 11 year old
gray haired miniature therapy horse.
Who's certified to go room
to room inside hospitals
to cheer up young patients.
We have him on the line,
along with Sue the
co-founder of victory Gallop,
a therapeutic equestrian
program just for kids.
So Sue I've definitely heard
of like therapy animals,
visiting hospitals, but never a horse.
This is unusual, right?
- Hey Kelly.
- Hi
- It is. It all started
with my husband Dave
and my brother-in-law Richard
in a two person horse costume.
And we would go through the local hospital
and just kind of visit
kids and romp around.
And then my husband who happens
to be an equine veterinarian
was on a farm call and
his client was trying
to rehome their miniature horse.
My husband called and said, Hey,
he'd be a great addition to your program.
So when PD arrived at the
farm, Kim and I were like,
wouldn't this be the coolest,
if we could train and certify a horse
to go right into the hospital.
So for 21 years, that
is what PD the pony did.
- Aww. That's...
- When PD passed, we were so devastated.
Cause we're like, what are we going to do?
How are we going to replace him?
And along came Willie Nelson.
And it's hard.
It's hard to train a horse
to go into the hospital.
And some of the things he has
to do prior to the hospital
is just to get multiple bubble baths.
He has to have his feet and tail wrap.
But the most difficult
thing that I worry about
is the elevator.
So his handler coral got in the elevator
on his very first day.
And I thought, for sure,
she'd only push button
one and she pushed seven
and I'm thinking, oh my gosh,
what if he won't get back in the elevator?
After we do this visit,
what are we gonna do?
We opened the door and there
was just all these kids
and he was a rockstar.
And now he's been doing it
for the past three years
every week.
- Well, of course Willie
Nelson is the rockstar horse.
I would expect nothing less,
but Willie is only one of many horses
that works with the kids, right?
At Victory Gallop.
Can you tell us about the program?
How many horses do y'all have?
- So we have 10 other horses
that are part of our program.
As you said,
Victory Gallop is a
therapeutic equestrian program
that works with kids with behavior
and emotional disabilities,
as well as life threatening illnesses.
We have about 80 kids a week
that come to the program.
And when they come to the program,
they learn how to groom the horses,
to tack the horses and ride.
And while they're doing this,
they interact with volunteers
and they also get to develop relationships
with kids that are dealing with
the same type of situations.
And what we've learned through this
is by these relationships,
with the horse, the
volunteers and other riders.
We can really make a
difference in their lives.
- 100% That you're definitely doing that.
It's a beautiful thing that you're doing.
Thank you so much Sue.
I'm liking your post right now, right?
Hey, what's up Willie Nelson?
- Thank you.
Well, that's not all Sue
our season long partner
pilot pin makers of G2,
the go-to pin of the Kelly
Clarkson show one to honor,
ultimate overachievers, just like you.
So they're going to write you a check
for a thousand dollars.
How does that sound?
- Thank you so much Kelly. Thank you...
- Absolutely happy new year William Sue.